my mom is amazing person yeah Lilith we
all agree we got a new phone
Jeanette castilian in Rosario Vargas are
a mother and daughter separated by a
border one living in San Diego and the
other in Mexico
I came from Mexico 2006 because I want
to get another opportunities for my kids
cuando se bueno MC no me destory de
penser came Eva said we're a little
evolved I wish I don't have the
permission to cross the border the line
from the last year and a half I see my
mom to the fence at the side of a by
national park in San Diego the u.s.
Border Patrol allows families to meet on
the weekends loved ones enter the park
and walk directly up to the border a
steel fence
this gives families on both sides a rare
opportunity to see and speak to each
other
no veo el Circo a parte comida tristeza
made Alegria porque voy a vera mija you
know you're gonna see your mom you're
gonna see your family but the fence and
they have a tiny holes in my mom
sometimes put the finger in the 10 yo I
just a little touch it just touch it or
sometimes I give a kiss
esta muy cerca a la vez tan lejos de
pouso tamale himself
sympathetically moocher on April 30th
for the third time ever authorities
agree to open the door allowing slept
families a brief moment to embrace each
of them will only have three minutes
voy a estar no sé como me voy a cent
evil a momento de que la puede hacer de
que puede goodbye right now I feel so
happy because I'm waiting and waiting so
much this moment time ever we have the
opportunity to have this door over
I feel incredible she was so happy she
was so sweet with me she tell me I love
you mommy I love you so much I love you
I love you